liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
heute vor 77 jahren endete europa der
zweite weltkrieg das schweigen der
waffen am 8 mai 1945 nicht eine
friedhofsruhe über den gräbern von mehr
als 60 millionen frauen männern und
kindern
millionen sind von ihnen auf den
schlachtfeldern gefallen millionen sind
in ihren städten und dörfern in
konzentrations- oder vernichtungslagern
ermordet worden
deutsche haben dieses
menschheitsverbrechen folgt
umso schmerzhafter ist es mitzuerleben
wie heute 77 jahre nach dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs erneut rohe gewalt
das recht bricht mitten in europa wie
russlands armee in der ukraine männer
frauen und kinder umbringt städte in
schutt und asche legt ja selbst
flüchtende angreift
für mich ist dies eine nacht wie kein
anderer
deshalb wende ich mich heute an sie
wir können nicht an das ende des zweiten
weltkriegs in europa erinnern ohne der
tatsache ins auge zu sehen es herrscht
wieder krieg in europa russland hat
diesen krieg entfesselt
einst kämpften russen und ukrainer
gemeinsam unter grössten opfern um
deutschlands mörderischen
nationalsozialismus niederzuringen
deutschland hat sich damals schuldig
gemacht an beiden nationen der
russischen wie der ukrainischen mit
beiden streben wir seit jahrzehnten nach
aussöhnung
nun jedoch will russlands präsident
putin die ukraine unterwerfen ihre
kultur und ihre identität vernichten
präsident putin setzt seinen
barbarischen angriffskrieg sogar mit dem
kampf gegen den nationalsozialismus
gleich
das ist geschichtsverfälschung und
empfahl dies klar auszusprechen ist
unsere pflicht
doch damit ist es nicht getan
es war der militärische sieg der
alliierten
der nationalsozialistischen diktatur in
deutschland ein ende setzte
wir deutsche sind dafür bis heute
dankbar
daher konnte der damalige
bundespräsident richard von weizsäcker
1985 vom 8 mai als tag der befreiung
sprechen
aus der katastrophalen geschichte
unseres landes zwischen 1933 und 1945
haben wir eine zentrale lehre gezogen
sie lautet nie wieder
nie wieder krieg nie wieder völkermord
nie wieder gewaltherrschaft
und doch ist es wieder passiert krieg in
europa
darauf hat der ukrainische präsident
selensky heute hingewiesen
in der gegenwärtigen lage kann dies nur
bedeuten wir verteidigen recht und
freiheit an der seite der angegriffenen
wir unterstützen die ukraine im kampf
gegen den aggressor
das nicht zu tun ist sie zu kapitulieren
von blanker gewalt und den aggressor zu
bestärken
wir helfen damit die gewalt ein ende
finden kann
daher haben wir in den vergangenen tagen
und wochen weit reichen und schwierige
entscheidungen getroffen zügig und
entschlossen durchdacht und abgewogen
wir haben nie dagewesene sanktionen
gegen die russische wirtschaft und die
russische führung verhängt um putin von
seinem kriegs kurs abzubringen
mit offenen armen haben wir
hunderttausende ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer aufgenommen
hunderttausende die vor der gewalt in
ihrer heimat bei uns zuflucht finden
hilfsorganisationen leisten erste
unterstützung schulen und kitas richten
willkommens klassen ein bürgerinnen und
bürger neben geflüchtete bei sich zu
hause auf für diese enorme
hilfsbereitschaft überall in unserem
land danke ich ihnen von herzen
und wir haben erstmals überhaupt in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik waffen in
ein solches kriegsgebiet geschickt
in großem umfang und immer sorgfältig
abwägen auch schweres gerät das setzen
wir fort
ich kann mir gut vorstellen wie sehr
diese entscheidungen viele von ihnen
bewegen schließlich geht es buchstäblich
um krieg und frieden
um unsere historische verantwortung und
maximale solidarität mit der
angegriffenen ukraine um die sicherheit
unseres landes und unseres bündnisses
diese ziele miteinander in einklang zu
bringen diese aufgabe stellen wir uns
tag für tag
dass wir als land über fragen solcher
tragweite intensiv miteinander
diskutieren
das gut und legitim zur demokratie
gehört auch solche kontroversen respekt
und gegenseitiger achtung zu führen
darauf hat der bundespräsident in seiner
rede heute morgen zu recht hingewiesen
aus vielen äußerungen die ich dieser
tage höhere spricht ernste
sorge auch davor dass sich der krieg
ausweitet dass der frieden auch bei uns
in gefahr geraten könnte
es wäre falsch das einfach abzutun
solche sorgen müssen ausgesprochen
werden können
gleichzeitig gilt
angst darf uns nicht lähmen
ich habe ihm geschildert was wir tun um
recht und freiheit zu verteidigen in der
ukraine und in ganz europa das ist sehr
viel
und zugleich tun wir nicht einfach alles
was der eine oder die andere gerade
fordert denn ich habe in meinem amtseid
geschworen schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
dazu zählt unser land und unsere
verbündeten vor gefahren zu schützen
vier klare grundsätze folgen daraus für
die politik
erstens keine deutschen alleingänge
was immer wir tun stimmen wir auf das
engste mit unseren bündnispartnern ab in
europa und jenseits des atlantiks
zweitens bei allem was wir tun achten
wir darauf unsere eigene
verteidigungsfähigkeit zu erhalten
und wir haben entschieden die bundeswehr
deutlich besser auszustatten damit sie
uns auch in zukunft verteidigen kann
drittens wir unternehmen nichts was uns
und unseren partnern mehr schadet als
russland und viertens wir werden keine
entscheidungen treffen die die nato
kriegspartei werden lässt dabei bleibt
es
dass es keinen weltkrieg mehr geben soll
erst recht keinen zwischen
nuklearmächten auch das ist eine lehre
des achten mai
die wir mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger ich
kann ihnen heute noch nicht sagen wann
und auf welche weise russlands grausamer
krieg gegen die ukraine enden wird
klar ist aber einen russischen diktat
frieden soll es nicht geben denn werden
die ukrainerin ukrainer nicht
akzeptieren und wir auch nicht
selten standen wir mit unseren freunden
und partnern so geschlossen und geeint
da wie heute ich bin zutiefst überzeugt
putin wird den krieg nicht gewinnen die
ukraine wird bestehen freiheit und
sicherheit werden siegen sowie freiheit
und sicherheit vor 77 jahren über
unfreiheit gewalt und diktatur
triumphiert haben
dazu nach kräften beizutragen das
bedeutet heute nie wieder
darin liegt das vermächtnis des achten
dass also die fernsehansprache von olaf
scholz vom bundeskanzler in diesen
dramatischen
kriegstagen in der ukraine am vorabend
von putins parade in moskau waren das
die worte in seiner rede an die nation
die worte von olaf scholz über die wir
jetzt diskutieren wollen in dieser runde
nämlich mit dem politikwissenschaftler
werner patzelt mit dem langjährigen
regierenden bürgermeister von berlin
michael müller mit alexander roth jansky
der den ukrainischen präsidenten
zielinski berät und mit dem langjährigen
nato general egon ramms so patzelt sie
haben vorher klare worte gefordert vom
bundeskanzler oder ist er immer noch ein
zauber kanzler auch nach dieser rede es
waren schon klare worte man darf aber
nicht vergessen dass er ja auch jeder
kanzler ist das deutsche volk
zusammenhalten muss gerade in diesen
krisenzeiten
und hier gibt es nun einmal sehr
verschiedene ansichten folglich muss er
versuchen das zusammenzubinden das hat
er wohl getan hat es an klarheit nicht
missen lassen wir scheinen das zwei
dinge noch hätten deutlicher sein können
das eine ist wenn er schon die berühmte
rede von friedrich von weizsäcker sie
zitiert dass wir damals befreit worden
sind es gehört zur historischen wahrheit
dazu zur befreiung sei es notwendig
deutschland zu besiegen keine freiheit
ohne sieg über die gegner der freiheit
und das könnte deutlicher sein denn wenn
man eine werte oder regelbasierte
internationale ordnung will braucht es
auch jemanden der die ordnung sicherheit
gegen regeln verletzt und das andere was
nicht ganz so glücklich war aber leider
in der deutschen rhetorik sich
festzusetzen scheint ist es den kampf
der ukraine gegen die russische
aggression gleichzusetzen mit dem tanz
derer die vom nationalsozialismus
unterdrückt worden sind mit dem
nationalsozialistischen deutschen reich
das wird der sonderrolle deutschland zum
zweiten weltkrieg nicht ganz gerecht und
das überzieht rhetorisch rotten jahns
die herr patzelt sagt gerade hier ging
es im grunde darum die beiden lager
heute in deutschland zusammen zu halten
das war im grunde der innenpolitische
rede ist ging überhaupt nicht um sie es
ging gar nicht um die ukraine ist ja
enttäuschend an wenn es war für sie
ja das stimmt also gebe ich ihm recht
und das deckt sich auch mit dem was ich
gerade gehört haben das war eine
deutliche aber ein auch vorsichtige rede
an die deutschen gerichtet damit sich
nicht allzu viele
wir haben dass der krieg eskalieren
könnte und so wurde das auch verstanden
als er rams das war kein zeichen der
stärke heute an die welt fragezeichen
das war eine politische rede
also ich sehe sowohl innenpolitisch als
auch außenpolitisch innenpolitisch ist
es richtig dass der wechsel gerade
festgestellt hat er versucht die ich sag
mal unterschiedliche meinungen in
deutschland zusammen zu bilden um eine
entsprechende klare linie halten zu
können oder einzunehmen auf der anderen
seite meine ich schon dass seine worte
und blick auf die unterstützung der
ukraine
auch den hinweis auf die freiheit die in
der ukraine auch verteidigt wird schon
deutlich macht sehr deutlich macht dass
offensichtlich alle im westen die
absicht haben die ukraine in dieser
frage weiter zu unterstützen und das ist
ein wichtiges signal auch an die eu
wollen also herr müller ihr parteifreund
ihr bundeskanzler ihm war heute die
größte sorge dass ihm ja die stimmung
möglicherweise kippen könnte hier in
deutschland also ziel nummer eins
priorität die beiden lager hier
zusammenzufügen in deutschland nein das
sehe ich nicht so ziel nummer eins war
und so habe ich die rede auch
wahrgenommen klar und selbstbewusst auch
zu benennen wer schuld ist an diesem
konflikt und das hat er getan es gibt
einen schuldigen das ist putin und er
hat auch klar benannt das in diesem
konflikt die ukraine weiter und da hätte
man schon drauf kommen können in den
fast zweieinhalb monate war daraus folgt
ja etwas das einerseits und die ukraine
klar weiter auch von uns unterstützt
wird und vielfältiger form unterstützt
wird aber natürlich ist es auch wichtig
dass er die sorge und er hat es ja
richtig so benannt die sorge vieler
menschen auch aufnimmt und ernst nimmt
dass so ein krieg eskalieren könnte weit
über die ukraine hinaus und dass der
bundeskanzler alles tut um diese
eskalation eben nicht stattfinden zu
lassen und dass er das so ausgedrückt
hat darüber bin ich sehr froh ich habe
ihn oft intern erlebt auch in der
bundestagsfraktion woher genau so stark
dass auch formuliert hat und dass er das
jetzt auch öffentlich macht glaube ich
war sehr wichtig